early ben dominic publisher of the
federalist juan williams fox news
analyst contributor
and trey gowdy former congressman from
south carolina ben
your thoughts about what we heard today
and what has come out of this
well unfortunately i think that what we
heard today is an indication that
once again the biden administration is
going to give up the store when it comes
to all of these different aspects of
american policy
and my question about their foreign
policy in this early going
really is what are we getting back in
return when we give them the north
stream
pipeline when we eliminate the sanctions
against the people involved in that
when we set these arbitrary red lines
that will
obviously not be honored when it comes
to russian cyber attacks
when we engage in restarting the iran
deal or any other number
of foreign policy decisions what is it
that america is getting in return
i realize that the criticism of donald
trump's administration
was that his approach to foreign policy
was far too transactional
there's some validity to that i think
that american
interests include an ideological
interest in favor of freedom
but there's also a transactional element
to foreign policy
and one that we ought to respect this is
not in any way a situation that i think
rebounds to the american benefit and if
the
the outcome of this is that we have a
stern talking to about
the potential death of alexei navalny we
have some warnings that are given
to the media and the like from joe biden
and we have them
oohing and awing over his gift of
american-made aviators
we're not really emerging from this
having achieved anything
in the american interest one uh you know
they had the dueling
press conferences vladimir putin's going
for a lot longer
um and then president biden's they were
not together and answering questions
you know the buildup to this was big
foreign policy experts
were waiting for this like you know get
around the tv get a bowl of cheez-its
and watch this thing
but what happened did it did it deliver
well i think from the biden
administration perspective brett it did
deliver because
all they wanted to do was hammer in
guardrails
to set what they want which is a more
stable and predictable relationship here
i'm using their
their words on this uh after the first
very tense six months of their ties uh
with russia being strained
and as you know overall i think the
biden administrations made it very clear
they view
all world affairs at this point as a
matter of democracies versus autocracies
uh china would be number one on that
list
but you know russia has the power uh you
know in terms of distracting and
disrupting
everything from the hacking to
involvement in
middle east peace deals you know aid to
iran to syria
and uh even in terms of eastern europe
europe with bel
berus and what's been going on in the
ukraine
so i think they wanted to just kind of
say here
is what our american interests are here
are lines that we are setting now in
this conversation
especially on cyber security i think
that was probably the number one was
in biden's words at the press conference
he said he let putin know
that the u.s has tremendous cyber
capability
if if that's the game he wants to play
uh and i think again it's uh it's it's
the cyber security
it's human rights no no revoking the
maginski act uh on uh russian oligarchs
and then finally i think you have to
think about the global stability you
know
stay out of our business right trey what
about giving a list
of entities facilities that are off
limits
to cyber attacks i mean are there others
that are okay to attack
yeah apparently that would include our
2016 election uh you remember brett our
country has been torn apart for five
years
because of an allegation that a
republican candidate colluded
with putin we don't have to wonder
whether putin colluded with putin
you have the guy in front of you who
tried to sow the seeds of discord
in our democracy did you bring it up
how about the indicted how about the
people mueller indicted the russians
under-indicted
under indictment i wonder if that came
up so i mean
if you got a list of things that are off
limits then you necessarily have to have
a list of things that are
within limits and i'm just wondering
where our election structure falls
in limits are out of limits uh you
mentioned ben
the kind of back and forth with the
press here's a little clip of that with
president but
um we know that there was cyber attacks
on a pipeline company in the united
states what do the state organs
russia have to do with that we are
encountering the same threats what
happens that ransom fair outfit were
sitting in florida or maine and took
action as i said
on their their their single lifeline to
their economy
oil it'd be devastating and they're like
you could see them kind of go
oh we'd do that but like whoa
so it's ever it's and everybody's
interested these things be acting
he denied any involvement in cyber
attacks he downplayed human rights
abuses
he kind of refused to say alexei
navalny's name
so how does that account to a
constructive meeting as a president
president you don't understand that
you're in your own business
to be a good reporter you've got to be
negative you've got to have a negative
view of life okay it seems to me
the way you are you never ask a positive
question why in fact
having agreement we'll find out we have
an agreement to work on a major arms
control agreement
a lot of back and forth there got testy
at times
ben you know joe biden has a long
history both
in the senate and during his tenure as
vice president of getting testy when
he's challenged in some of these areas
but it
is an aspect of his character that only
seems to come out more
in this day and age unfortunately all
these questions are very valid
and ones that ought to be answered
responsibly by the president
i think they would be directed at the
president of any party engaged in this
kind of
interaction unfortunately i don't think
that we got any real answers
from joe biden i don't think we're going
to get any real answers from this
administration
because unfortunately this meeting only
redounded to the benefit of vladimir
putin
it did not benefit us in any clear way i
have no idea what we got from this
putin got ambassadors back he got to
laugh at the press leaving the room
he got to assert that there were certain
areas that were off limits and
limits when it came to ransomware
attacks and the like as trey said
and unfortunately i think that that is
really an example of weakness when it
comes to
our approach to this we never should
have had this meeting in the first place
given everything that's happened in
recent months juan i mean just respond
to that
well i think it's important we had that
meeting because of the tensions that
have existed for the past six months
because i think you want to avoid you
know
this is an old sort of arcade term but
cold war we're not interested in
having any battles with russia look we
hold the aces in this let's let's just
i mean i'm not trying to be you know
overly
boastful about the united states but our
economy is 15 times the size of russia
canada has a bigger economy than russia
their economy is basically a gas station
you know based on oil and gas
and that's a declining asset in the
modern world
so when he does something he is just
basically
a disrupter and what you have the
president of the united states holding
all the aces in the conversation saying
is here here's the deal mr putin we'll
see where this goes but we're telling
you we don't want to fight with you we
want a stable relationship
don't antagonize that's all the more
reason that we didn't have to meet with
him
to say that this wasn't something that
was necessary
our last ward is a country within an
economy the size of italy ripped apart
the greatest super
power on the face of the earth for five
years and there needs to be a
consequence
for that for biden it was a brief
bipartisan moment both republican and
democrat presidents don't like cnn so i
marveled at the bipartisanship
there for just a second all right we'll
leave it there panel we'll see in a bit
up now